guys if you haven't heard trash taste is
going on tour yes me and the boys are
going to be touring north america in the
month of september and october so if you
live anywhere near saint paul chicago
cleveland detroit toronto boston
philadelphia new york city washington dc
rayleigh nashville orlando dallas austin
kansas city denver salt lake city
phoenix la san francisco seattle or
portland we are coming to you all the
date should be on screen right now
tickets have been on sale i believe la
is already sold out and other cities are
already very close to selling out so if
you want to get your tickets today go to
trashtaster.com that is trashtaster.com
link's in the description as always
[Music]
we are
so sorry guys
we
a lot of times which you can now watch
on our patreon
we do we do mess up yeah we do we do for
those of you who are our five dollar
patrons by the way thank you very much
you guys will know that you'll get early
access to clips as well as uncensored
and uncut episodes but we have extra
stuff for you guys now monthly behind
the scenes content we [ __ ] up so much
that we can make a whole new video of
just our fuck-ups every single month and
we will present that to you to our
patrons on the five dollar tier so if
you do want to go and watch those you
can do but just for you know feeling a
little generous the first behind the
scenes will be available you just smash
that link down below to the youtube
unlisted link and you can watch the
trash days behind the scenes so head
over to patreon.com trash chase if you
want to see what we have to offer on
with the episode we always talk wi-fi
louder let me tell you about this thing
you beat your guest
permission to speak
hello and welcome to another very
special episode of trash taste we are
joined by another guest today i'm sorry
i completely forgot it's been a while
since i've hosted yeah i'm your host for
today gant and with me are as usual the
boys
and today we have a very special guest
now in case there is one person in
youtube who don't
doesn't know who you are do you want to
introduce yourself and uh what you do oh
my god that's a lot of pressure uh uh my
name is anthony padilla some people say
padilla i'm totally fine with that but i
do like to say padilla like tortilla
um
that's how i get people to memorize it
um let's see so i god how deep do we
want to go into this history here
youtube
okay let's get deep guys uh so i started
uh with my friend ian i started a
youtube channel called smosh in 2005
17. what's smosh 17 years half of my age
ago oh my god jesus half of my age half
your life has been on half of my life
yes oh [ __ ] i'm having to rethink so
many
i'm gonna need that two and a half hours
yeah
uh and then in 2017 i kind of split off
to do my own thing been doing an
independent channel which has slowly
evolved into me
kind of doing deep dive interviews with
either groups of people or one person
that has um
you know
some kind of popularity surrounding them
right we get we we drill in deep into
uh
the psychology behind uh blowing up or
you know if it's a group of people
um i like to kind of get in there and
understand them yeah i feel like so many
people have preconceived ideas about
what a group or what a label or identity
means so i like to kind of show that
there is variation in nuance from
individual to individual yeah they're
really good yeah thank you i mean this
is like pretty intimidating because not
only are you like the og of youtube like
i can say that you're you're like
you are not even like it's not even like
a subjective yeah yeah you're
objectively you are you are the og of
youtube but also you are like now the
interviewer of like youtubers and now
we're interviewing you so i'm like first
engineer
my stuff is so different when i came
here i was like so what are we talking
about today you're like
i don't know
when i go into mine i'm like okay okay
i've got like this 45 bullet points i
know where to get through these i i over
plan so much this is just
my favorite stuff is always the stuff
that comes out of stuff that happens in
the moment that was never planned and
that is your whole job
it's your whole show
yeah yeah on youtube it'll say top
moment all of it yeah yeah all over
cause kind of hit me when you came and
you were like so what are we talking
about today guys and we just look at
each other and we were just like what do
you mean oh [ __ ] we're talking to uh
anthony today [ __ ] he's the interviewer
and we don't have any interview
questions
i was like uh do they have some kind of
secret thing that they're not telling me
some kind of prank that they're gonna do
they're like should we tell them no
we're gonna hit you with a low blow in
about 30 minutes
let's grill me yeah it's actually i've
always wanted how much how much prep do
you do for your interviews because as
we've just established we do zero crap
here the only the only prepping we do is
who are we getting
today yeah um let's see so the shows
start i call it i spent a day with
whatever the topic or whatever the
person's name is and at first it was
like four people i would sit down with
and it would amount to like eight hours
now it's a little bit shorter like two
to three hours if it's just one guest a
little bit longer but
i do a pre-interview call which is like
an hour hour and a half or two and then
i work backwards to try to figure out
what we're going to talk what questions
i'm going to come up with based on the
things that we talked about so yeah
god i cannot even question it's a lot of
pressure yeah what made you start doing
pre-interviews is it because you maybe
had some guests somewhere you're like
[ __ ] i could have done a way better job
like a little bit of that it was also uh
bringing on guests that
have really big stories and i felt like
i couldn't just go in there and be like
so um tell me about your childhood and
then just like did they just go and i'm
like i think they probably got
everything like i i also i realized that
in the interviews i was cutting out a
lot of stuff right right you know i was
like it's a lot of me trying to figure
out where this is going i kind of want
to have an idea of where we're going
first yeah and i realized uh that i was
like every night before
the the next day was an interview i
would be like up until 4am like 12 hours
straight like [ __ ] i don't know what i'm
talking about i got to learn every
single thing about this person's life
like drill down you know i interviewed
youtubers that's actually how i found
out about this podcast i saw that you
had interviewed some a v tuber as well
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly
um and i like i watched that episode and
then i was like learning everything
about youtubers i was like
wait i could just talk to them have them
tell me the important things and then i
could reverse engineer the questions
based on the conversations that they
want to have yeah so basically you
you take out some of the research time
where you don't even know if you're
going down like the wrong rabbit horse
yes and instead you just come straight
from the source i guess yes yeah and
then i'm able to use the extra time that
i now have during the interviews
to uh kind of drill in deeper to like um
like this the psychology behind the
feelings that they were having and what
things affected them from those moments
and how they affect them now yeah and i
guess it just allows me to get a little
bit deeper with the conversations yeah
so like yeah so like the interviews are
like 20 to 40 minutes how much of that
is like how much source like footage do
you have how much of it gets cut out you
reckon yeah uh so it depends the person
uh markiplier we shot like two hours and
40 minutes and we cut it down to a half
hour somehow miraculously after it came
out he was like holy [ __ ] you did it you
bastard
but uh we apparently like were able to
get all the the key components the
conversations that were
really meaty have them in there while
cutting out all the fluff and it's it's
a it's a lot of
there's a big process that we have uh
we have five editors now it goes it goes
from person a per they all have like a
very specific
uh they're like a specific cog in the
machine yeah and uh it's a lot of just
like grinding it down it goes to the
first person they get the full two and a
half hours of footage they cut it down
to 50. and then it's like that person
takes and cuts it down and each person
is like really good at refining we just
have a one-man machine
yeah yeah he's like he works like 10
people's work
i'll do it myself yeah damn
i do have a solution to that problem you
know if you if you're like coming in
with like two and a half hours of
footage and uh having a hard time
cutting it down oh yeah have you ever
thought about this thing called a
podcast
you mean just releasing it all right i
never thought about no cuts
i have thought about that and people
have asked they're like come on just
release the full thing i know you got it
there somewhere
uh but i feel like i'm too much of a
stickler for like i want it to really be
polished i want everything that i come
out with to feel polished and i know
that i know there's an environment where
people want
longer conversations that are unedited
like this one obviously has a huge
audience even on youtube where i feel
like people are not generally looking
for very long uncut things you guys
found that audience
does exist yeah but i just i really want
something that feels a little bit more a
little bit more bite-sized but you could
like take those like cut parts that you
cut out for example turn it into like a
compilation release it on like patreon
for like behind the scenes oh yeah yeah
have you thought about doing that for
sure yeah we definitely have a bunch of
like archived conversations that
we are noting this didn't really make
the cut yeah it is still a strong
conversation i mean with with the amount
of questions i guess you're asking and
the amount of people you're asking i'm
sure there's moments there you're like
that question didn't go down great oh
that that was a little awkward let's
just cut that out let's just
a little bit but some well it depends
sometimes the awkward questions and
answers have like yeah are the best ones
because it force it puts me on the spot
to come up with something that was
unplanned
and i uh
i overthink everything that i usually do
that it's the unplanned stuff that
actually gets the like gets out of my
head because i'm actually you know there
in the moment yeah uh but yeah sometimes
it's i just move right on
yeah you're like all right next question
sometimes it'll keep me in keep keep it
in of me being like uh so anyway uh
me not knowing where to go with it like
when i interviewed dominatrixes and some
of the details that they said yeah uh i
didn't i don't think there was any
response that would have felt
appropriate in that moment right about
some of the actions that went down
behind the scenes
yeah
i think i'm a little too vanilla to have
uh been prepared for yeah
is there a lot you have to cut out to
let's say
keep within youtube guidelines
i mean to a certain degree yes sometimes
we just censor it and that's enough yeah
because we don't want the video to be
age gated and yeah
no one sees this video right um
i mean certain episodes yeah i spent a
day with strippers i spent yeah matrixes
you i mean i'm gonna have an upcoming
episode i spent a day with pony players
look it up actually or maybe not maybe
with us private maybe with a private
browser incognito window what is a pony
player
so they are people that uh it's
basically role play it's a little bit of
uh dom and sub dynamic
and they dress up as a pony kind of in a
leather
like like my little pony or
uh like
or just like an actual pony think about
a humanoid oh here we go we got we got
some visuals for you
can you click on that black and white
one there i think that one's a pretty
good dynamic yeah let's let's let's zoom
in on twitter oh
uh let's
take a look oh wow
yeah
we don't put these off it's like uh it's
like a leather furry a little bit
um except it's bdsm so it's not a furry
because those are not always associated
with anything sexually who's scouting
this stuff for you uh yeah
i mean a little bit yeah it's uh my
producer elise she's like uh
so we got this uh really interesting
person she has a um an arena you know
where horses usually um reside in but
it's for the pony players do you want to
do you want to add on a little segment
where you go on location i was like
yeah let's do it
i didn't know how to react to that but
the obvious answer is yes right yeah
it's the context you have to i mean yeah
when i when i do a lot of episodes i
spend it with dominatrixes i'm like
you have to dominate me like that's hard
that's power into this but you have to
have to journalistic integrity so many
comments are like clearly anthony just
wanted to know what this was like or
like clearly anthony's a pro at this
because he didn't really have that big
of a reaction i was like
i i mean you know transparently i just
wanted it's part i wanted to learn about
dominatrix isn't the scene i have to put
myself in it to really understand of
course the dynamic of why people would
do this what do they take out of it yeah
what do they like about it yeah how do
you how do you battle the inner
embarrassment
you know it's the weirdest thing when
it's when it's on camera and it's it
feels like it's for research purposes
literally yeah
to the point where
and part of the humor and entertainment
comes from me being embarrassed which
makes me less embarrassed yeah i guess
that makes sense yeah i do videos in
japan similar thing yeah i worked in a
strip club recently yeah yeah i i did
not see that one specifically
okay are the strip clubs that are
different
ah yeah a little bit i guess i mean i
haven't been to any here oh oh you
should tell me for research
research processes
yeah i mean that i i feel like yeah when
you're on camera it kind of gives you
like a free pass to just yes
embarrassment yeah
not good
i realized that the other day i went to
this uh this bar i never
there's there's this social anxiety
that's just like uh uh immediately like
cut off any opportunity to to feel like
out of my element yeah right so i went
to this thing i was like i'm just gonna
push myself to do and i was like
why i was thinking i was like i could
totally do this if cameras were on me
and if it was like i'm like
talking to the camera i'm gonna be going
this thing i'm gonna be uncomfortable
let's see what happens yeah i would be
able to totally do it yeah and i was
trying to
reframe my mind to be like can i trick
myself into
there is a camera following me and i'm
doing this for research purposes because
i would be a pro i would be a pro with
anything invisible
it's my invincibility
i'm like i could do anything if a camera
is on me i don't know it's weird tell me
you're a youtuber yeah
you're just like concentrated like
through influencers
it empowers you it feels like you have
like a pass to just do it yeah yeah yeah
like oh no don't worry he has a camera
on him
like if these cameras were not rolling
and we were all just sat down up there i
feel like it might have taken us an
extra 10 minutes to warm up you know
it's weird right there's like
you
this
feel from being on camera yeah because
like normally like most my content is
not on camera and the only time i
started going on camera was like for
this podcast and like at first i was
like really really awkward and it was
just really really weird being there but
then you kind of get used to it and it
kind of becomes your friend right and it
kind of becomes like it'd be kind of
parasocial
it becomes like you're amazing you're
the audience oh no the camera the camera
comes like coming comes like the get out
of jail free card
you wouldn't normally do that's true
because part of the entertainment factor
comes from whatever happens yeah yeah
yeah so you're forced to lean into this
yeah and people around you as well as
soon as they see you being being filmed
they're like yeah okay they could they
can be a bit of a monkey absolutely get
a free pass i'll tell you what is like
the real free pass though so you
sometimes in japan we have like we bring
like the camera crew but for some reason
every time we've brought like a boom mic
that is that is when like people around
us know that shit's going down
because they they you know they see like
a shotgun mic yeah yeah they're like oh
well you know this is just like a hobby
for someone you know just filming for
their friends
but when they see a massive boom like
they're like oh this is real [ __ ] right
here like this is like yeah they got a
crew
excuse me gentlemen do you want some
coffee
they immediately think we're like more
important than we actually are when they
see the boom yeah we don't even use it
most of we just use lapel microphones
yeah yeah yeah it's just like a relaxed
man yeah
free card uh but i i was thinking back
to i was like there were there have
definitely been moments of things that
i've shot that i would be so embarrassed
if the cameras weren't rolling and i uh
i did this video i spent a day with
anime cafe maids uh
yes uh i i said if this video gets over
100 000 likes i will become a maid and i
will
make a documentary about me doing a show
and i actually put it on put the show on
with the girls that i had interviewed
yeah and i look back at that and i i had
the most confidence in the world like
zero bit of embarrassment about
literally stepping on people and having
my full-on ass cheeks out yeah so i was
like if the cameras were not rolling i
would have been like i don't want this
attention yeah it was something
something about the uh knowing the
cameras are there and i'm trying to you
know almost like i'm working like i'm
[ __ ] working here guys like something
about that i was just like it's okay
yeah it's like it's like a little devil
that's sitting on your shoulder like
don't worry it's for
content i don't know if that's a good
thing i don't know if that's a good
thing just like a professional through
and through you know it's it's like you
know when you're an actor and the
director says like you know [ __ ] yeah
what did they say again
you need action know this
i'm sorry okay i'm sorry it's only been
five days in l.a okay
i i feel like like when i go into a lot
of the videos i'm like i will never get
a chance to do this again like you can't
make it true yeah
like
you could do the video again but you
can't really no no it will never be the
same reaction no one's gonna click it
again or they will but you know
it's not the same it's not the same i i
was having a conversation um with
someone recently and
i was trying to figure out why i feel
like i'm in such a different head space
when i'm conducting an interview right
part of it is that i've done a pre-call
part of it is that i know where the
conversation's going to go to a certain
degree but also
in many ways i feel like
it might be it's like the last
conversation i'll ever have with this
person not to say that like i'll never
talk to them or or whatever again but
for some reason there is like this is
this one moment yeah in a way it feels
like there's all this count yeah yeah
and even though there's a lot of
pressure
it for some reason the fact that it
feels so dire it almost alleviates the
pressure in a weird way right yeah
knowing that you can kind of go for this
the deep questions and yeah yeah yeah
like this is your one shot yeah like
what you were saying right right yeah
that's awesome when you started did you
ever feel like i guess nervous being too
intrusive or you know kind of like
diving down a bit too deep yeah a little
bit i mean i would tell people
beforehand like if there's any question
that you don't want to answer like don't
ever feel like i'm trying to pry further
than you're comfortable yeah like i
would tell them like tell me to not if
yeah
going down in direction that you're not
comfortable with but now that i do the
pre-calls again that that removes most
of yeah sometimes i'll drill down a
little bit further but for the most part
i see if they're comfortable and i try
to word the questions in a way where
they can tell me as much as they want or
go in as much as they want yeah
sometimes they'll tell me something if i
want to get in deeper i'll be like oh
and i'll kind of rephrase what they just
said to me yeah which
sounds really stupid if you like if we
just leave it in it's me saying the
exact same thing that they said but for
some reason hearing it back i feel like
they know that i understood and then it
gives them the opportunity to
to refine or dig in deeper if they want
yeah so usually it's like i kind of
throw out little invitations to go
deeper without feeling like i'm prying
in okay right right so it's like it's
like their choice if they would like to
go down if they want to yes yes right
exactly that's pretty smart to do yeah
sounded like you're describing uh
it's their
choice
and after
so like obviously like you see it's like
a massive interview series on youtube
now but you came off of this like off
the back of smosh what made you want to
start doing this series was it did you
want to explore a bunch of ideas and
then this was the one that like kind of
stuck or was it always this that you
wanted to do well i mean you know smosh
was definitely a
comedic like silly
thing so i never thought that i was
going to get into
any deeper conversations like connecting
with people in the way that the series
is now
um and
the whole series kind of started off as
a joke of course the the very first
video when i left i was like okay part
of the joke was that i'm an independent
youtuber now i have no idea what's going
on
i'm a strong independent youtuber i was
feeling feeling myself um and it was
actually very true i didn't i had not
uploaded my own video in years because
the company had taken it over right so
part of the joke was like hey what what
does a
youtuber independent youtuber do now
when i was asking for advice and i uh
interviewed a bunch of popular youtubers
and
there was something about that
dynamic of having a conversation where i
didn't know where it was going and the
funniest moments were the ones that were
improvised rather than 100 scripted yeah
and i really enjoyed that and then later
on it was like let's
revisit and i was like struggling for a
long time just floundering like what do
i do with this channel and every every
single week it was like i don't know
what to do okay i figured it out okay i
shot it okay i hate it so now i'm gonna
figure something else out okay
now i'm releasing this thing that i
don't really like but i ran out of time
yeah and uh eventually i was like what
were the things that i liked doing most
on the channel so far let's uh you know
i'll dial in deeper with those ideas and
then i started expanding on it from
there yeah yeah man japan needs to start
like listening to how you do your
interviews because you would hate how
interviews are done in japan i don't
think i've ever heard a japanese
interview tell me about oh god do you
guys get interviewed like on japanese
anyone you have to give them the exact
script oh yes
there's no room for yeah and they will
sometimes have scripted answers about
what they will say to you back so
everything is pre-planned there is you
are not allowed to go out of like off
script
and it's just the most rigid interview
you could like ever imagine is it is it
like that in different places of asia as
well because i have made i've also
interviewed someone from south korea um
and it was a similar thing right
well they were speaking english to me
and it was obviously not their first
language so it's like of course they
want to know what they're saying yeah
yeah uh they wanted the questions
beforehand
and i i figured yeah they want to know
what i'm saying to them just in case a
word slips by that they don't know yeah
but i didn't realize what they were
doing was scripting their responses to
such a degree that afterwards they sent
me their script yeah and oh wow and
whenever i i thought it was a little bit
weird in the moment whenever i'd asked a
question they would repeat the answer
that they had already said and i was
like okay well they were a lot more
loose in the pre-interview just talking
about all these things
and then here i was like maybe they're
just nervous or something okay i get it
people get nervous yeah but then they
sent me the script and it was verbatim
every single word that was said yeah i
think they had a teleprompter yeah i
think like because i i've done quite a
bit of interviews with like industry
people in japan and like a lot of them
are like okay send me your list of
questions beforehand we will approve all
the questions we will write up like a
very basic thing and i'm like okay
that's fine but i've done enough now
where i'm just like okay we'll follow
your script but i'm gonna add extra
questions yeah yeah and you won't be
prepared for them and so i can really
catch you out on what you actually feel
and for the most part they're okay with
it when it actually happens but i think
if you tell them beforehand hey by the
way i'm going to throw in some extra
questions they'll just freak out yeah
because they'll be like we're not
prepared their teams will say like yeah
their teams will be like no you can't do
that but when i do it on the day of the
recording and i get a good answer and a
good conversation going then they're
like oh
maybe it's okay yeah maybe it's actually
maybe it actually makes for an
interesting interview
they're not out to [ __ ] me over yeah
exactly maybe they actually are just
like genuinely interested in me want a
good interview i wonder how many people
have to be screwed over like in order
for that to become thus like how many
bad interviews what have you done
to get to that point yeah yeah but it
does take a while to kind of build up
that rapport that rapport and that level
of uh respect or trust yeah
with people you know and i've seen that
too i i'm i have people that are a lot
more comfortable with doing my
interviews now than i think that they
probably would have been a couple years
ago before i'd really
um you know i don't know if i want to
call it proven myself but like i guess
proven that i'm not going to purposely
and maliciously try to like
defame someone and ruin their career you
never really showcase even like you know
what most people consider strange things
you never really show it it's like whoa
look at this weird thing you're just
like these are real people let's just
see why real people do what they do yeah
yeah if it is a strange thing i i like
to talk with them about how yeah yeah
and the thing is most people
are absolutely willing to talk about how
something that they do is strange
it's not like they are so like
in a different world that they think
everyone should do this and if they
think it's weird then [ __ ] you you know
what i mean yeah yeah
but you've probably you've had people
like that though right in the past in
which way in the in the sense of like
them trying to prove a point and being
like no you're weird for thinking that
this is weird kind of a little bit but
it's still it still seems a little
playful they're like normies don't get
this
so so they they still i think recognize
that but yeah definitely people are a
little bit defensive but i think it's
because they've been shown enough times
that they
like they they almost they feel like
they have to be defensive because that
means that someone doesn't respect them
and i think it's just a lot of like
vying for respect of people yeah
yeah do you often find like do you ever
find people that it's it's it's a
different field where you're just
talking to someone casually but when
you're in like in an interview setting
with cameras you really have to like
make them feel comfortable like being
themselves and talking like do you did
you find that a challenge with your
interviews at all just getting people to
be comfortable on camera as quick as
possible a little i mean yeah and you
bring up a good point i i do obviously
have a limited time and i can't just
spend the first like hour of the
interview warming up yeah yeah yeah i
i
i go out of my way to really connect
with people um you know we have the
pre-interview call so there's a little
bit of that dynamic where we're already
laughing together and we already are on
the same page so there's that when they
show up but of course they're a little
bit more tense but
i you know i'll meet the guests on the
street i'll walk them in i'll bring them
out to the back we do our covid tests
and we like hang out uh you know like on
this park bench that i have on my
balcony and we just chit chat and uh i i
get to know them and i you know tell
them a lot about myself so right
i think that there's there's like a
method to
kind of warming people up to so that
they can see like that you're genuine
and that you're not secretly going to be
trying to get a one up on them you
should have done that
you're taking them out back
now we used to do something similar we
called it like i don't know i don't know
if it was a strap but the denny strat so
we there was a denny's outside of our
office yeah often out like invite them
to like lunch beforehand yeah like get
to know them have a casual conversation
but one issue we always
found ourselves having was we'd get into
a conversation and it would just be like
[ __ ] this is this is good material this
is gonna be it literally happened like
the five minutes since we sat down and
we're like [ __ ] yeah let's just like not
ask any questions
this is like good material that we can
get yeah
yeah yeah and that's part of the
challenge also i mean that's
the closer you get to someone the more
you start connecting with them the more
you start talking about things that are
then difficult to bring back up and have
it feel like the first time you talked
about it yeah but that's what helps
having my my questions already yeah
because we actually go away from those
conversations for a little while and
then
if we have a good conversation
uh you know i'll write it down in my
notes and i'll be like this is a good we
need to bring this back up again yeah
right yeah smart we should take notes
this isn't a podcast we're just
literally just asking for advice
[Music]
how do you do it you guys didn't have to
get i could have just sent you a message
it's like where were the questions bro
yeah no this is great so we're talking
about before like how many people you
have to like run the show now so like
how many people are there behind the
scenes and how many did you start off
with yes so uh i started off with just
two camera operators and it was just
myself trying to figure out what the
[ __ ] i was doing
um and then i i slowly but surely had
new people come on to help me and now i
have
10 employees on the show jesus and uh
you know it's it doesn't sound like that
big of a number until you think about
how much everyone needs to be paid
there's a lot of moving parts so
um you know
from
when i started i took two years of
community community college and i
started to take business administration
classes right i i smosh started
happening 2005 and i was like [ __ ]
college but um
i realized i've actually always been
interested in kind of managing a team
and a business and yeah i think i think
it's a lot of fun you know teaching and
especially once you could teach like i
have a head of post the main editor and
i get to teach him all the things and we
get on the same page and then there's
four people that work um
i guess below him as how people would
say it but that work with him and so i
get to communicate with one person he
communicates with four so uh i just
really enjoy the dynamic of a whole team
working together and have it having it
feel like uh yeah
because because i was going to ask like
how many people did you have at most
when you were at smosh like oh my god
how many points did you have then uh
it's it's kind of hard to say because
defy owned smosh right and
they i think had 30 people working with
smosh and all the side channels and live
events and the
live yeah all the there's so many
elements there that i guess 30 was the
the magic number i i i don't even think
i met some other people
it was it was a weird team situation
where we all never really got to know
each other fully obviously you know
we're youtubers you see that lovely one
out of ten system which is the most
depressing system on earth yeah it's
very black
system in the world
our viewers have heard us complain about
it like a million times but yeah i
imagine when you have 10 employees that
yeah suddenly if you're getting a ten
out of ten and then maybe you get a nine
out of ten it starts to get a lot
scarier right when you yeah yeah yeah
there's a lot more weight yeah yeah i
mean how do you deal with that it's like
a did you deal with it like as a team or
are you like gosh leave me alone i'm
gonna cry
i there's still a part of me that is
affected by it i can't say that there's
not yeah um
it's and it's not not even like an
outward thing of like oh [ __ ] dude what
am i gonna do but even if i just carry
on with my day there's like a part of me
where like my energy feels a little bit
like something was pulled out from me a
little bit right even if i'm not
thinking about it it must be some
suppression
and then when there is like a 1 out of
10 i'm a little
my posture is a little better
i i've been really working on reminding
myself that like
uh a bad video now was actually a good
video for me like
in terms of performance yeah when i
first started um you know what i would
now consider like probably a lower
performing video was it was a good
performance and we still have sponsors
and i
still i try to look at what my actual
progress has been for the show it's not
just views that is it's so easy to think
views are a measure of progress because
they are it's the biggest number when
you go on youtube it's attached to every
single thumbnail in fact many people
decide if they're going to click on
something based on how high that number
is yeah you see one video and it has um
you know 10 000 views
someone is much less likely than to
click that same video with 10 million
views because there's a curiosity aspect
of
wait wow
so many people are watching this has got
to be something
right if there is a youtube video under
30 seconds that has over a million views
you know you know what you're gonna get
you know what it's like always a [ __ ]
youtuber and that shit's gonna be
delivered to you with so quickly 30
seconds yeah that's it 30 seconds to
have a banger
uh but you know that is not my only
measure of where i'm going with this
yeah part of it is also like the
the i want to grow respect and have
people trust that i will treat them with
respect on the show so i'm having uh
people have with huge names people have
started to reach out to me and say like
oh i'd love to be on the show sometime
and that's something that i never had
before so regardless of where my my
numbers go i have people that i really
respect reaching out to me and wanting
to talk with me and like have that
experience of being on the show and that
is something that
is so cool and i could clearly see kind
of that's my message
yeah yeah
yeah i mean was that so the whole
youtube system and giving a [ __ ] about
analytics was that something that i
suppose that smart underdefined media
that you never concerned yourself with i
didn't really because we were just on a
salary right right so i was like these
numbers don't affect me yeah i came in
there like anthony man it's not doing
too hot yeah i'm like i'm like oh man it
looks like i have two more years
yeah so it must have been like you were
under smosh then under defined media and
then now you're separate so there's
probably that big gap where you didn't
really take notice of what was really
happening
wow that's interesting so now i had to
start learning all these yeah yeah yeah
yeah when did you kind of tune out of
like giving a [ __ ] about what was
happening on youtube or like kind of not
paying as much attention and just doing
it
you mean like when i was defiant yeah
yeah yeah um i'd say it was probably
around
20
14 or 2015 probably to 2017 when i
eventually left and decided to do my own
thing yeah right um i think it was the
two years that i was unhappy with where
things were going and the way that the
company was being ran and the decisions
that were being made and how i was being
left in the dark about a lot of
decisions that were
really important that were being made
right and
it was around then that i started to
just kind of tune out from youtube in
general you know i would still put
a lot of my heart into making the things
that i was making at that time but yeah
there was still this part of me that was
just getting detached from it and that's
when i kind of stopped caring about
browsing youtube and being part of the
community as much yeah just when you
thought you were out you got drag
yeah they almost made it out of the rat
race so do you think like not caring
about it gave you more or less freedom
than you do now because now you have to
really you do have to care about the
algorithm every youtuber has to care
about the algorithm unfortunately i
think it's kind of about caring about
the right things and by the right things
you know it's not to say there's a wrong
thing to care about but like the
figuring out what is meaningful for you
and then caring about those things right
right it's so easy to start caring about
the things that seem like they matter
most like you know just straight up view
count yeah um you know but then you
could drill in you could read the
comments and see how much of an impact a
certain thing made yeah um and you know
you could realize that that is more
important so you have to define the
things that matter most to you before
you just start caring about everything
yeah yeah yeah yeah damn so like you
mentioned something earlier just off the
cuff but you were just like yeah so i
quit college in 2005. because marshall's
a thing yeah what yeah so so you quit in
college in 2005 to do youtube yeah wow
well okay
i said it a little wrong so i went i
went to two full semesters so i think it
was technically 2006 right and i was
signing up for classes
and
i was thinking about the amount of time
because the classes obviously get harder
the further along you get with your
um
with your degree yeah um because they
start dialing into the actual difficult
things and i was like okay i could be
doing all these extremely difficult
things for this yeah or
um you know which is now taking my time
away from this other thing that is now
starting to build that this is a once in
a lifetime opportunity yeah to um
i felt like i was almost like the master
of my own fate with this world well i
felt like uh getting a college degree
while obviously super helpful for most
people i i felt like this is something i
can always come back to right yeah and
also this kind of puts me in a position
where
i'm kind of like
following a system that other people
have put in place for me i felt like i
was making up my own rules
so did you like foresee
the [ __ ] ecosystem youtube would
become or you're just like no
no
i'm like
i see it all you were confident
no
don't just have this like because
obviously how many videos or like how
where were you at at that point when you
decided to go to college yeah what kind
of stage was it at i think we had
how many
i think we had six videos out yeah
oh my god yeah did you ever recommend to
a youtuber with six videos no
never do what i do never do what i do
unless your parents are very well off
and they're totally fine with you not
doing good they want to help you how
many subs did you have when you quit the
subs were not a thing
they were called followers and
they were not a thing but the the reason
that i felt confident is because this
outside company that was competing with
youtube called
it does not exist anymore yeah they
reached out to us and they were like uh
they gave us this contract that was in
hindsight very shitty but
we were college kids who were still
living under our parents roof and we
were like you know what this makes sense
we could fund
these things that we love doing like we
just had the best time hanging out and
just laughing our ass off creating
things and like yeah
college because that's what the college
kids really want to do most of the time
so we signed a two-year contract with
this outside company yeah uh they they
offered us 3 600 bucks
to split between us but for two years so
for for two years each no no each month
okay okay oh okay
i know i know i know
it sounded worse it's still not great
though
uh so we each got 1800 bucks and we each
also invested
our own money from that yeah into
the videos themselves and they also give
us a little bonus at the beginning so i
got to like i this piece a [ __ ] car so i
and like i couldn't do anything because
every time i got my car it was like not
where anyway so i bought a new car and i
was like you know what
this like we have a two-year contract
here we're pretty safe i could come back
to do these classes if i if i really
that makes way more sense yeah yeah yeah
it was like one of the one of the first
deals where a company was like trying to
compete with youtube
and uh part of their contract was uh you
this video has to be exclusive to us for
two weeks
and after the two-week period uh you can
release it to youtube but it has to have
a brought to you
tag on the front and at the end and a
watermark on it so so we like generously
they even let you do that
it was but their their whole uh strategy
for marketing was that
they were trying to steal the audience
from youtube right yeah yeah yeah so the
only way for them to get an audience on
their platform was to let people know
but unfortunately they didn't have
anything to offer yeah that was out that
was bigger than the scope of what
youtube had to offer yeah yeah i don't
need to get into the legality behind it
but eventually we were able to get out
of that contract because they promised
us a certain wow i don't know if i
should have said that company name
you want to bleep it out
on bleep it out okay yes thank you bleep
out the company name
so now i feel more
i feel comfortable saying everything
um
so
they promised a certain amount of
marketing value and they translated that
to a certain amount of views it was like
some odd millions of views they were
promising to bring to our videos on our
channel on their platform okay they did
not live up to that and uh when we
started getting on them about that we
found out i'm wondering how much i
should say this is how many years ago
now jesus is 16 years ago jesus uh maybe
it's okay i think that there everyone
there is probably um in a different i
don't know buried underground yeah um
uh so they
they what i realized they started doing
to to fulfill their end of the bargain
right was um well first i noticed that
we oh we had a million new views on our
video on this channel this day
okay so this this website where our view
videos usually get 5000 views are now
getting a million five thousand views
right there's something up here
so
oh
so so i go i go into the comments and uh
i get um
who [ __ ] smosh what is this [ __ ] i'm
trying to look at my mp3s and this is uh
why is this play i i find out that they
also own this other website and they
have a little hidden iframe
uh that's like auto playing our videos
in the background of this other website
oh [ __ ] so they'd go
go to this website and then they'd hear
the audio of our videos while they're
trying to [ __ ] browse this other
website and it would count as a view
oh my god so eventually we were able to
get all the contracts we were like this
is not very cool it's actually giving us
a bad reputation because people think
that we are doing it yeah yeah and then
eventually we were able to get out of
that and it was at that time that uh
both
oh my god my space was trying to
launch
launch a video platform i'm not sure if
kids today know one of my favorites no
no it's it's it's your space
uh so they were trying to launch a video
platform and they came to us with a with
an offer and then youtube
uh was like hey we're gonna there's this
program where you can make uh money on
your videos on our platform that never
had any ads before would you like to be
one of the first 10 channels to
ever make any money on here we'll give
you a guarantee and even though their
guarantee was lower than myspace thank
everything in the world we said uh yeah
we'll stick with youtube yeah and that's
kind of where everything started that
was early 2007. that's what
was that just like were you just just
guessing or did you genuinely feel like
i think youtube's gonna be the king
there was this
feeling also we had a video on our
pokemon theme song lip sync
like youtube videos
uh
so that video i think had something like
25 million views
jesus christ and
it was easy to see that the the market
the the viewership was on youtube and
they had just been purchased by google
for you know way too cheap
and which is still billions of dollars
and
i felt really good about google i felt
good about where they're going even
though i met tom from myspace you know
myself i was like um google you've been
the creator of myspace yeah yeah briefly
uh he was just a dude i mean i don't
know a dude wearing a nice jacket
he did not i feel like everything within
him was like i i can't do that i can't
even give a thumbs up or smile
no no he was he was a good guy
did he add you in my space um was it we
were already friends bro
yeah but was he in your top eight
friends that's the real question he
became part of my top eight after i
thought he might have a deal with him
i'm like [ __ ] if he's going to my page
he's gonna know
um i think he's photography now and he's
a good photographer but anyway yeah um
so i i went with youtube we went with
youtube ian and i made the decision to
go with
youtube there and obviously it was the
right choice yeah it just felt right you
know yeah yeah right so you were getting
paid even before there was even like an
economy on youtube yeah yeah you know
the funny part is that the all they were
was the lower third ad the little tiny
thing that pops up at like 15 yeah
and even then
you know we were afraid of
the backlash that we might get for
that's so funny so
yeah yeah yeah
we enabled it on our older videos and
then the newest video we'd waited till
like our audience bigger audience came
in and left so that we wouldn't get
flack for it and even on our older
videos people were like whoa you [ __ ]
so loud
it's an ad where you go your mouse
everyone no one's on mobile you're on
your computer all you have to do is move
your mouse and click the x and people
like
[ __ ] this there's one extra step
now people watch videos and there's a
minute and a half unskippable
like whenever youtube gets sponsored
they're like yes king make that money
yeah yeah but no did you get like
backlash when you had your first sponsor
because i i feel like i feel like
everybody's wondering i think yeah oh
you mean smoothie king is that what it's
not your first one it's the first one
it's called smoothie king it was this
like i don't know if they're independent
or if they're like a chain but they're a
smoothie place in like austin texas or i
forget somewhere in texas i don't know
and uh yeah we just had to make a little
video there and put it up we didn't put
on our main channels our second channel
yeah they paid us like a couple thousand
or something and it was it was like you
know what was the reception to that
though um what the [ __ ] is is this
but early youtube she's so wild
there were absolutely
no rules and i remember when i first
started i would actually uh go out of my
way to break rules to show youtube that
this rule could be broken
i'm just a bad boy
and um one thing that i realized is that
there was this channel that
um i can't remember what the name it was
in fact it's probably better that i
don't say that yeah yeah they
they they had videos that would just pop
off but they'd have like 12 comments and
i was like
this this math doesn't add up yeah and
of course as an 18 year old kid i was
like i must get down to the bottom of
yeah it's my duty
uh incident detective mode yeah yeah
yeah
so
i did a test on our myspace and um it
was it was kind of what i learned from
that other company doing the hidden
iframe thing
so i realize on on myspace you can hide
an iframe as well right
which is ridiculous i think that anyone
could have any page load in the
background yeah so i hid it on our page
and um
i realized that that worked so i said
youtube um fix this i don't know i don't
know if it was even me saying it but
also a big thing was that that channel
was also having
hundreds of thousands of new subscribers
i think it was right when they announced
subscribing right yeah
and uh i was like how is this channel
that gets so little comments having so
many views and subscribers so i also hid
an iframe on our channel that are on our
myspace that auto-subscribed people to
our channel and after like a day i was
like yeah this is gross i'm not gonna
have this on here so we removed it we
got like 100
200 new subscribers i felt gross about
it yeah and i think and you know in
order to repent for my sins i went to
youtube and i was like
this uh is a way that people are
cheating the system yeah so then youtube
like within the next couple days added
uh on the subscribe page they had a
little button that said are you sure you
want to subscribe was that was that back
when you could actually talk to youtube
yeah
especially if you had a big audience on
youtube you had it was like concierge
just kind of get [ __ ] done oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah we went and hung out in um i
don't know i don't remember saying i
don't know san bruno san jose some some
sand
sand
san francisco yeah and um you know hung
out with people there that worked there
and then wow chad hurley steve chen the
creators of youtube yeah dude um you
don't have enough subscribers yeah
look at the good old days right
it was so rare though for people to have
an audience because most people that
uploaded videos to one of the video
clips we're one-off viral clips so it
was very rare for people to have
audiences and have recurring
you know videos of a specific channel so
i think that they really treated
everyone back then as like their gems
that were like keeping the channel or
like making
something bigger because i remember back
in the day it was just like you would go
on like the most viewed you go on like
the most viewed of all time and like
obviously the pokemon lip sync was there
evolution of dance
yeah because i always forget at one
point you were the most subscribed
channel yeah yeah two separate times two
separate times yeah it's like a three
month period and a eight month period or
something i forget how was that like how
how was it at that at one point you were
at the top it was it was really cool was
it pressure though i bit there was al
there was definitely pressure and it it
um
it filtered the way that i looked at
everything that i did yeah um for better
or worse there was there was the good of
like oops everything that i make has
some kind of value i should put a lot of
my time and energy in this because i
know a lot of people are going to see it
and it really pushed me to constantly be
pushing myself outside my boundary or
out of my comfort zone because i knew
that it would you know not literally pay
off but it would pay off in the sense
that a lot of people would see it and
potentially be able to enjoy it yeah and
on the opposite side of that there was a
lot of getting in my own head about
um the pressure and how i have to live
up to this and then you're also always
seeing comments of people saying like
how is this whatever and it's a lot of
um filtering it out to be like
it doesn't matter that some people don't
like this it's not for them
but it would get in my head of like oh i
need to i need to be better and it was a
lot of like this this pressure um you
were mentioning earlier about how
obviously when you started you got the a
deal from a company yeah i imagine when
it was starting to ramp up and get to
like number one most subscribed you're
probably getting offered all sorts of
weird and predatory stuff and just
probably just the most stressful company
meetings ever
dude we had
we had someone show up to my house was i
was living with my mom obviously like in
just like our small little tiny house
yeah yeah
sacramento california and there was this
predator i i don't want to call him
predatory but there's this guy came up
in a business suit he's like
knocked on the door my mom was like
there's someone outside oh no
so ian and i walk out and we're like
uh
what is up and he's like oh um i got
your address because i saw that you just
registered for a business and it was
marked under this address so i figured i
would just show up and tell you a few
things about like what you could be
doing what the [ __ ] how you could be
monetizing this and i was like
i was 18 so i didn't know and it was my
first time with like any kind of
fame or
i didn't know that this was a [ __ ] up
thing to do yeah so i entertained it and
come on
would you like something
i drew the line there
there was no invitations inside yeah um
but he would luckily he was a vampire
and he could not enter without me uh
no so he
he was like okay so your pokemon theme
song music
[Music]
like video this epic cinema a piece of
piece of cinematic work uh and he was
like it has three million views
so think about it this way i could get
you sponsored by coca-cola oh my god and
if if you get a thousand dollars per
million that's three thousand dollars in
your pocket like that and i was like
first of all
do you actually know
do you have any contacts with coca-cola
and he just started listening and i
realized immediately that he was full of
[ __ ] he was trying to make some kind of
a connection and he was like but like
then mcdonald's and i was like
dude so he clearly didn't know what he
was talking about luckily uh he only
showed up one other time after that yeah
i was like mom when that guy shows up
again you just ignore that
the bad man in the suit leaving
um
but
luckily we were uh i mean we were not
very smart but we were smart enough to
know that that did not feel right right
yeah right yeah yeah because we were
talking to like sean jacksepticeye like
a few weeks ago and how back in like the
early days of youtube there was just no
boundaries between fans and like the
creators so fans would literally show up
at his house oh yeah yeah did it happen
to you a lot oh absolutely
yeah yeah so uh ian and i ended up
renting this place together um he and i
and we had another roommate with us too
and um we lived there for i think four
years and that's when our videos were
really really really starting to become
popular like right 2009 to 2011 is right
and
there are
so many ridiculous stories of like mobs
of people
like i'm trying to edit in my editing
room and there's like i just hear like
people running around the house and like
laughing and like looking through our
trash
it was people did not know boundaries
because we were really stupid
so like all blame is on us but
because this was also during the time
where you were doing the mail unboxings
on the screen yeah yeah so i bet like
that also came into it as well right
yeah i remember like you know back uh
back way back when i used to watch this
mail in boxing oh yeah those are my
favorites i love them
i think
at that time it was something so unique
because obviously you know you know big
massive celebrities would be getting
this kind of stuff but i think it was
the first time that like a normal person
could just watch somebody receive all
sorts of weird [ __ ] yeah yeah
like this is so weird
it really did show you the scope of like
how strange yeah yeah the common person
can be with the items that they choose
to send yeah yeah yeah and the drawings
that they choose to draw
that must have been weird oh yeah yeah
what was some like the weirdest stuff
you ever do i have some very good
go-to's for that don't you worry okay
yes we got we got ziploc bag of dead
bees
[Music]
what i want to know
how did they collect those they might
not have been bees maybe they look like
bees i did not examine enough to know
for sure
we have a slightly smaller we have a
slightly smaller thinner bag of nail
clippings
oh
yeah everyone didn't receive [ __ ] as
well at one point um
we received stuff that smelled like [ __ ]
that we never ventured out
with it yeah yeah yeah i i felt the
texture yeah
it's like this is definitely
give it a little smell elephant [ __ ]
um
we definitely had uh boxes and we
received so many boxes that we would
sometimes just throw in our garage and
they would sit in the humidity
and it would be months before we get to
it and people thought it was so funny
that they would send us
uh sandwiches
and these sandwiches would just rot
and oh because of like the food fight
stuff i don't know why but it became a
thing and the bags the ziploc bags would
you know inflate with the gases from
these things
and then the scent would just permeate
throughout our entire house
yeah you'd throw away the boxes once
they were kind of um you could see like
patches kind of sopping wet or oily or
greasy
um but that quickly was like it's
probably about time to stop uh receiving
the mail like it was fun it was a great
time period how long did you guys do
that for i think we did it for like
three or four years oh my gosh
and by the end it was years of stuff
just built yeah towers and towers a man
oh god yeah but i guess every now and
then you probably get something really
[ __ ] cold you're like yes yeah yeah
we received some really cool [ __ ] oh man
lots of lots of used video games and
then i would just take them all to
gamestop and be like
use video games
and then they'd be like 100 credit i was
like two games i actually won
that's so big
like ponies and cats
so many weird games that i would never
be interested in playing i was like i
can convert these into games i want to
play
yeah just giving junk yeah just trying
to get rid of it yeah
well we we were given um a lot a lot of
stuff that we were given were um
just like
people are looking for things to send
yeah yeah yeah i'm going to send you
something yeah and they didn't want to
spend money on just sending because they
didn't even know if we would see it
right there's no guarantee we didn't
even know if we would see it in fact
some of the things i hope you know it's
probably better off we didn't see half
the things that we did
but people would send us just old stuff
that they wanted to throw away yeah
because i wanted a garage sale or
something right it was like old shirts
that had not been washed in years and at
all oh yeah because it was to them it
was probably just like yo that's my
shirt
yeah yeah yeah so then we had to start
being really selective about the things
that we showed we had to stop showing
the [ __ ] stuff yeah the dead stuff
the body the human body the human body
the the anything that came from a human
body was no longer making it in the
videos yeah
yeah we realized that we were
encouraging it and then we also
accidentally encouraged people to send
us money because we had one video where
someone um a few people sent us like one
dollar bills so he's like oh we got 10
bucks and like it was kind of a joke and
then uh then we had to make oh we got a
hundred bucks and it was like we need to
stop showing money all together yeah and
we realized that anything that we showed
was a direct call for people to send us
more of it right so eventually we had to
stop showing the weird stuff or the
really grandiose stuff because we didn't
feel comfortable with either right yeah
someone might feel bad if you show off
like something really amazing and
they're like oh and i guess
charlotte from like mexico sent me this
like [ __ ]
and a lot of people were saying really
sentimental right right hand written
things that we could never
actually like if i wanted to read every
one of those and i really wish i could
because they were they were so heartfelt
like it would have been a full-time job
to do that yeah nothing else yeah yeah
which is a great problem to have yeah
i'm interrupting this episode of trash
taste to give you an important
announcement this trash's episode is
sponsored by boxu anyone who watches
trash taste will know that we are big
fans of boku if you haven't heard of it
yet oxu is a monthly scription snapbox
service that delivers premium japanese
snacks and tea pairings straight from
japan to your door first box who you
receive is called seasons of japan
following the seasons of japan you'll
receive a new monthly themed box every
single month like this one this one's
theme is
oh onsen vacation you know me and the
boys are always talking about our onsen
vacations and this theme you can get
snacks from places that are famous for
their onsens each boksu is packed with
snacks and it comes with a cultural
booklet that tells you all about the
theme where the snacks come from details
on all the flavors and it even teaches
you a few japanese words and phrases
baka now i would like to try
oh yes
it's a rice cracker snack and i love
these
so if you want to try some rare japanese
snacks and support japanese family
businesses and support our channel make
sure to go and order a box by smashing
that link in the description down below
and don't forget to use coupon code
trash taste 15 to get 15 off your very
first boxu order back to the episode so
you mentioned like you know you were one
like pretty much one of the first
creators to get paid for doing what you
do on youtube when did you start to
realize oh this is this is like serious
now this is like gonna get big
i mean it depends like there are so many
different uh levels of big like at that
point i already felt like it was a big
thing right right when we because i was
like we're one of the first people to
get paid on this platform that i foresee
is having longevity yeah yeah yeah um
but
in terms of like
i don't know it was a little bit dicey
though so that was 2007 and then four
years later i didn't really know what
the fate of youtube was going to be yeah
and and we had an offer from a company
which ultimately um you know their name
ended up being defy right and they
offered us then to
buy our company for stock
it's totally great idea
well you've talked about this a lot in
your video yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um obviously didn't end up being worth
anything so how did they pitch it to you
in a way that you both were like yeah
this is a [ __ ] great idea let's do it
like how did that like happen
yeah you know and it is a complicated uh
i imagine yes too because because you
know uh
that like the state of youtube in 2011
it felt really like we didn't know where
it was going was that before or after
the google plus thing they tried to
shove in
no that was 20 that was when i first
started so that was like 2014. yeah yeah
[Music]
i think it lasted like a year and they
caught up maybe and then they were like
now we're getting rid of it youtube has
been constantly at especially in earlier
days it did seem like it was like what
the [ __ ] is it it was it felt very
fragile
yeah right yeah so so they presented it
to us as
um you know we're gonna take all the
website smosh.com stuff off your plate
because i was doing all of that yeah
myself uh because you know i was
actually i actually made money before we
started getting paid on youtube by
designing websites for people right
right and that's how we i was able to
fund a lot of things and you know side
tangent the
uh our videos actually started getting
we made like two lip sync videos before
the pokemon theme
before before we found out about youtube
and
um i i hosted it on my own website yeah
and yeah
there was because there was no website
like youtube to host it on yeah yeah
yeah yeah and uh
i created a little thing it was a again
it was an iframe a copy you copy paste
there and when you paste that to your
page i had instructions and everything
when you copy paste it's your myspace
page it put the video there and then it
also had instructions to copy and paste
for someone else like that was how i
designed this like
uh like copy paste viral kind of thing
all right and uh i didn't know how well
that was doing with the two lip sync
videos it's so weird to say that
we did beforehand
uh but i did get the the bill i did see
the bill and it was a couple hundred
bucks you know
and i didn't know how to convert that
into how many views is this getting but
i knew it was getting a lot of views or
else i wouldn't have to pay a couple
hundred dollars for bandwidth on videos
right um so you actually used to have to
pay
yeah bandwidth before youtube offered
the service so we found out about
youtube by me doing a search for one of
the videos i found that someone else had
uploaded it to youtube and i sent him a
message i was like hey this video thank
you so much for uploading it here uh we
want to upload it ourselves do you mind
removing it and they said yeah
absolutely so
we created our channel smosh was still
five letters still available yeah and uh
that was the beginning of that damn uh
shoot i forgot where we were going we
were going with wi-fi he asked me about
that why did defy like how did that all
come how did they pitch it to you okay
okay yeah okay i got off inside the
engine because i was talking about how i
designed the website
trash station's all about just don't
worry we're can write in write it yeah
oh yeah seamless um
so
they came to us and
they were like we will take care of the
website so you no longer have that
stress to deal with because every week
the website was crashing and i was
figuring out how to
you know keep it up and i they they had
this huge plan of all the things that
they were capable of and how they had
the infrastructure to allow us to do all
of our dreams so they asked us what do
you want to do with this company if you
could make this company anything what
would it be and we had these huge lofty
goals they said we got all of that on
lock we have the infrastructure we have
the investors we can make this happen
right uh and they offered us a certain
amount of money in stock yeah it sounded
really good more money than i thought
that you know i would ever see in my
life before that yeah so i was like that
sounds great obviously this company is
eventually going to go public that's how
they work right yeah i did not know
my lawyer did not tell me that that's
not always the case the people that we
had surrounding us that
were authority figures in some way to us
on the situation did not break down the
details and how that doesn't always
happen and how it's that's actually a
huge risk
so
they bought full ownership and they paid
us um in uh yearly you know annual
salaries right and they had this
structure set up where it's like this
year yeah it's pretty shitty salary but
next year it's a it's an okay salary but
by year four you're gonna love your
salary so did that happen it it it did
eventually out that way and i was i was
uh pretty comfortable with it i was like
we are making a good
uh salary here like we what do we really
have to complain about and i guess
they're doing a lot of the
stuff that you used to have to do and
they're looking at things and managing
it but then also imagine as a youtuber
it's probably quite difficult to give
that control it was because i did give
that control away and everything was not
how i would have done it
i ended up working double time to teach
them how to do the things but then they
were rehiring and the way that bigger
companies work is like you're never just
building a one-on-one relationship with
someone who like you teach them once and
they know and they keep going with that
thing and it's just a thing that happens
now it's like no you're re-teaching and
re-teaching and re-teaching until it's
like okay let's abandon the website and
then it was like me abandoning a lot of
the things that i
had a dream of growing because i was not
able to keep that up and also do the
videos yeah i had to figure out where to
put my time yeah was there a specific
point when you kind of realized damn
this is not what i envisioned at all
when i kind of went out like was was
there a specific moment or was it just
like a build up of like a lot of things
it was
primarily a build up over a long period
of time it was about four years in
when i realized
that things just weren't looking right
and i still had two years on the
contract left right
and uh i think one particular thing was
like they hired um
someone that i did not know that they
were going to hire and then all of a
sudden i found out that they were now a
full-time employee in this like really
important position that meant something
to me and i was like wait i didn't
realize that was yeah what was gonna
happen yeah yeah and also there were
times and i don't know how much i could
say
but i'll see what i can do there
they don't exist anymore
true technically uh
there was
uh a fundraiser that they they put on it
was for a game
and they had just seen the success of
other people who had done fundraisers
for games indiegogo gofundme type things
and they raised like 250 000
for like these games which were like
mobile games but you could play it on
the computer and it was like this really
cool thing with all these inside jokes
from the community right and they said
oh that's cool guys you do that and then
we were like we don't have a concept for
a game they're like ah we'll figure it
out later you just just
just raise some money they just made the
fundraiser and then they were afterwards
they were like make the game and we said
we need to have something to pitch to
people yeah you need and then they're
like cool we'll just tell them the idea
then because and then they're like you
come up with the idea so i came up with
the idea ian of course also we both came
up with the idea and uh
they were like
uh cool you got the idea
let's let's do it i was like we need to
have concept art we need to like show a
build of the game we need to be able to
show what we what we want to do with
this thing they're like ah we don't have
time okay we'll get concept art so all
we were able to do was launch with this
concept art wow and uh
launching a campaign
asking people incentivizing
your fans to give you money well that
did not it did not feel right to me but
i felt backed up into a corner yeah and
um you know i think that's probably one
of the things that i regret from my time
there yeah is allowing myself to feel
backed up into a corner
to accept money from people that were
excited about this thing being built of
course you know we did accept money for
that and i did put all of my heart and
soul into making it as good as it
possibly could be still didn't live up
to my expectations and i feel like it
was done the right way it would have but
the
the moment that really stood out to me
was there was some there was some
shadiness about
um you know obviously the way that they
pushed to earn money for something
because they saw dollar signs right no
because
yeah rather than it being like
those types of things if you're gonna
have your audience fund them it should
really be a passion problem yeah yeah
yeah yeah absolutely exactly and i could
have made it a passion project because i
really was excited about it but it was
so forced and you know rushed
and then um
there was um
uh some some shady stuff about like the
way that
they contributed to certain donations to
make to inflate certain
the way that certain things looked and
that's really all i'll say about that
but it made me feel so weird about it i
was like i need out as soon as possible
yeah right i imagine when they were
doing stuff like that the confidence you
had in the the company was probably a
bit like okay if they're willing to do
this stuff yes not be going so and i
realized that
the way that they treated
that was the same way that they were
treating me and all the other people
yeah so a lot of people lost a lot of
money right i mean it was like crazy
what was it i a lot of people lost a lot
of oh yeah yeah eventually luckily i i
i wouldn't say i foresaw anything but it
didn't feel right and i got out a year
before they ended up closing down right
yeah um and another thing that that
really was a turning point was
uh i i had made a facebook page and it
was i don't know i had like 500 600 000
um followers or whatever we call it
just like subscribers
uh and uh yeah it was just it was smosh
anthony and they were like oh this has
smosh the name so this is um
we're gonna run this for you okay i was
like okay yeah yeah sure and then i was
like
hey you know i was kind of trying to
start to silently transition out i think
they kind of picked up on the gist
because we still were contractually
obligated but i was like um can i can i
get my my facebook back they're like
no it's ours i was like oh
but i i made that thing and you said
that you just wanted to run it because
you were going to help me post content
on there yeah yeah yeah yeah like it has
smosh in the name this is ours
that's [ __ ] up
okay
and then i i easily settled on that i
was like oh okay okay it's fine it's
just facebook who cares facebook and
then they were like
um they're like okay hey can we get
access to your twitter and instagram
i was like no no
and then i i immediately i immediately
changed the name from smosh anthony to
anthony padilla
after they asked me for access to that
yeah in a way it's kind of cool that
they uh
kind of forced you into being like you
know what [ __ ] this i'm just gonna go on
my own yeah [ __ ] brand myself really
it really got me thinking like
could i do something on my own
like outside of this brand that i had
created
yeah and it was really sad because i had
made that brand uh
yeah when i was 14 years old i i made
that as like a little shitty website as
like a forum for me and my group of
friends at school to to go on and hang
out with each other it was really before
social media it was like we were either
talking on aim or we were going on this
website and uh
yeah it was sad to kind of let that part
of me this like this baby that i had
brought into this world yeah kind of
kind of go yeah god it must be
nerve-wracking trying to do something
yourself though right because like as a
as a youtuber like starting like
ditching your channel which has like
millions and millions of subscribers to
start to start from the ground up again
yeah like i think like you were one of
the first people i know like first big
creators to really like branch off and
try to do something themselves with a
new channel right and then it succeeded
and like there wasn't a precedent set
before that really that you could really
succeed by doing something new right i
mean what fred did it oh yeah fred had
another channel and then he did his
thing well he did a few movies
yeah yeah i did a movie yeah
i was doing a movie i was doing a movie
that was also another weird experiment
a part of me because obviously i mean do
you
it's not a good idea
i was just gonna [ __ ] i shouldn't
think i hadn't said it
but
[ __ ] about my pride and joy listen i'll
get it i want to talk to you right you
actually did you actually watch that
yeah i loved it
i love i love it in a way as well
yeah it's it's a terrible movie
it's so [ __ ] cool
that it's good yeah but it's so fun
amazing part of youtube history where
like everyone had to have a movie yeah
yeah youtube for some reason was like
make em [ __ ] movies yeah pump them
out fred had [ __ ] john cena yeah yeah
yeah
i completely forgot about them it was
just a [ __ ] cool weird time yeah
where people were making movies whereas
like i mean did you even want to make a
movie was it like what was that like
what was going on with that like because
i feel like there must have been so many
people trying to put their fingers yeah
no it should be this it should be this
no no no [ __ ] that we should get john
cena in it yeah
yeah oh we got a song called steve
austin oh yeah
from the wwe
well i was like john cena's not happy
it's gonna be stone
yeah i want to know about the movie like
what what what was all that
yeah uh so we i mean yeah a lot of
people had movies going on a lot of
people were breathing down our necks
saying so when are you gonna make a
movie yeah and
we we did kind of have this
dream of eventually making the movie
version of a smosh sketch yeah yeah yeah
and we we had a lot of uh we nothing
concrete but like ooh what would the
movie version of this look like do we
get uh if we get a million dollars do we
uh
some we had some of the dumbest ideas of
like where the movie was all
uh smosh sketch uh budget and then we
had millions of dollars worth of money
pumped into the final scene
that was our initial idea no because i
remember on the smosh channel i this was
way before the actual movie came out
yeah you guys released an april fool's
video yeah smosh the movie yeah we did
it have you seen this video i think i've
watched this this was like the last ever
like april fool's like youtube video
that i saw but it was like the first
five minutes was like the most insane
quality like oh my god this looks like a
movie yeah and then the remaining hour
and a half was you and ian walking back
home
with no cuts
this is the greatest thing ever so then
when i heard that you guys were actually
making a movie yeah i was like yeah say
psych
for youtuber movies it was the what was
the name of the one with the ghost uh
ghost mates ghost mates that was one of
the better better youtuber movies i will
say that one was that was that one we
had a little bit more freedom with and
uh in a weird way though we we almost
stripped out a lot of like what made
smosh right with that movie so it felt
weird because it like wasn't quite
um you know a good movie and then it
wasn't quite uh
you know bad youtube movie which is also
entertaining for its because you and ian
are i think naturally very good on on
camera like compared to like how some
other people transitioned to the movies
kind of thing i think you and ian did
that a lot better i think it definitely
helped that you guys were already acting
in your sketches yeah yeah yeah there's
a lot of that going on acting
acting in your sketches
i i heard a lot about how uh i should
improve my acting uh in the comments but
uh really oh yeah because they're gonna
go into it they're gonna be like you're
a youtuber you can't act yeah yeah yeah
even if you did an amazing job like stay
in your lane yeah yeah
yeah
yeah but with the movies you know with
the first one it was a lot of um you
know we did have the stream to do it but
then other people you know it was at
defy they they were like um we need to
make this happen and we need to make it
happen in four months
four months
okay i'm just throwing a random number
it could have been six it could have
been eight but i think it was somewhere
probably around six months jesus and we
were like um actually no i remember it
was after we got to a point in the
script writing process that they said
this needs to happen in this very short
amount of time we're like we're not
ready
we're still like fleshing this thing out
yeah and uh
it was a thing where we still wanted to
make our videos on youtube we didn't
want to give that up because we felt
like we would have had to drop that in
order to put all of our effort into
making a
movie yeah and they were like don't
worry we could hire this person and they
gave us a few options they hired a
person the script was not anything like
i would have wanted it
it was a lot of like someone on fiverr
yeah
we found a guy
it was a lot of like here's what someone
who
isn't in the youtube space thinks our
videos and thinks youtube is was there
someone who like worked in like you know
hollywood hollywood movies
it was like a hollywood uh script writer
who who did like tv series and i think
some movies as well right and he did do
some funny stuff but um it was very much
like an out-of-touch perspective yeah
and it was like i mean a lot of smosh
stuff was cringy in its own right but
like i was cringing at it yeah at how
out of touch these things were i could
not do these things
there was this like area where like
memes go to die that he that that was
written where it was like a space
uh was that in the no no no wait [ __ ]
there was it [ __ ] i don't think this
john's so familiar yeah you know i think
that ian might have talked about it on a
separate thing okay that's pretty long
yeah this sounds so familiar or maybe we
he and i both talked about at some point
but there was this part written where it
was like where memes go to die and it
was he was like
uh he was like tayzonde is in there and
i was like okay first of all you're
trying to make us say that these people
are dead
this sounds so that's kind of [ __ ] up
and then also you are saying
here's all these things that are not
in the now like we're it's just this
weird period piece that just feels too
soon to be a period piece you know
whatever yeah it might age poorly yeah
it also just sounds like a hello fellow
children moment right yeah
yes i know memes yeah i don't mean
culture
it felt a lot like that and then we we
did a lot of rewrites and it was still a
very bad movie yeah thank you
how how it feels a little too hot
how self-aware were you or like on set
to be like
guys are we are we making like i think i
was half self-aware right right i wasn't
fully self-aware part of me
thought
like after a certain scene happened i
was like oh that might actually be good
part of me did think it might actually
be a good movie depending on the way it
was cut depending on the way the special
effects look yeah uh but the way that it
came together was very much i was like
after i was i was we were seeing like
final cuts of it i was like okay
that's the movie well i mean at least
it's not as bad as shane dawson's movie
that was yeah i mean it depends who you
ask because no that one was really
really bad was it
i i did but i saw it like on the
premiere night where there was so much
hype in the room from all the friends
and family that it was hard to tell yeah
yeah is this a funny joke or am i just
not in a good head space right now
you should go re-watch it sometime
maybe i will yeah that's interesting
okay okay i never even tried that no no
no
okay okay well it was a lot of fun
though and i i think that some elements
from the you know from the smosh
sketches retained
their
smoshiness yeah it's much easier for me
to sit here and be like you made a
[ __ ] movie
like i could do anything yeah yeah yeah
like my movie would be good
oh you gotta make it in six what
i can't even spell
it was a weird process because
you know we had trailers and yeah
we you know we had an acting coach and
we had the pressure of like this is the
movie
uh it was something like a million
dollar budget so i was like you got like
the full hollywood it was the full
hollywood experience
and uh you know we had like a writer
there on set to like do rewrites in the
moment if we needed to rewrite something
for time and like there were a lot of
scenes that we had to cut for time and
like they were rewritten on them it was
such a different experience where it was
not
like i could still go to the director
who was alex winter and he's amazing you
know yeah um is he the bill i forget
he's the bill or ted from bill and ted's
excellent adventure the knock kiana
you know oh he's the ted i think
no bill i don't know
the one that's not key yeah yeah yeah
but but alex winter amazing and and you
know his his kids were huge fans of
smosh so he really did want to give it
that genuine smosh view not sure what
matt's calling it
no matter how much heart and passion
you put into something if there are a
few elements that are slightly off it's
gonna all fuel it's gonna kind of all
get brought down to that level i feel
like that's what happened there were a
lot of great things that could have been
but then it was like there were certain
elements that just kind of brought it
all down oh we got to cut the scene
because of time that doesn't make you
probably feel very confident you're like
that's not good yeah yeah yeah but but
you know a lot of times we're like we're
going to cut this scene for time and we
end up having this other scene that
totally actually worked fine without it
and it was like the rewrites were okay
yeah um well they were your like
sketches before scripted so you already
already had were used like memorizing
lines or were you like mostly improvised
before yeah yeah they they were
definitely scripted uh okay but usually
we would like get a take that we like
and then we'd be like go off book for
the fight
half the time we'd go with the off book
version right um but it was a little bit
different so smosh videos we would shoot
uh you know 10 second clips of like this
thing okay you say this thing okay you
say this thing and uh you know when we
do when you do a movie they they really
want you to get like the full scene with
this angle than the full scene the next
angle no jump cuts no no [ __ ] jump
continuity yeah so a lot of the
acting in it was actually me trying to
remember my lines
if i watch it i'm just like i'm just
trying to remember my lines right now
most of these lines like it didn't
really get past that and also
i got in my head a lot about like
i don't think this is going to be the
movie that i yeah yeah that i wish that
could be yeah it would be so hard to
like really turn up and give it your all
when yeah it just doesn't feel like it's
going wrong it was hard it was like
after the first day even though there
were so many people that had a lot of
passion and
good intentions and a lot of people that
did put their heart and soul into it i
after the first day i was like
this doesn't feel like it's going to be
what i thought it would be and then it
was it was hard to get out of my head
and get out of that right i guess you
couldn't exactly go to define be like
hey
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
it's like not like a youtube video we
just shot the first day yeah
it's like the sketch kind of isn't
working let's let's scrap and go to a
new youtuber
let's do a new video you know yeah yeah
well even even down to the sketches it
was hard to say this video didn't work
oh really because there was a lot of
money that was invested into it yeah and
we were given a certain budget each
month right and uh if we scrapped it it
would be like this is cutting into our
overall budget let's just try to make
this work
so so when that pressure starts building
up and you have all these other eyes and
voices and
budgets and restrictions
that's when i think things start to kind
of go south in those situations right
and that's when i started to feel like
things weren't really
right even though like i could totally
see why you can't reshoot a sketch after
you shoot it
obviously it makes sense yeah yeah but i
think if i was fully independent there
were a lot of things that i might have
considered yeah reshooting but but
when we have this uh level where we want
the production value to be there and we
kind of reach that point it felt weird
to go back i now know that you could go
back and it's fine but
back then you're like holy [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah would you ever want to make
another movie with the correct amount of
time and creative freedom oh man anthony
padilla the movie
i don't know i don't have any any drive
for that i i have been pushing myself
more with
the intros of my videos on
my channel that i do now it is scripted
and i realize that none of the the
passion that goes into me writing the
words makes it on the camera when i'm
recording this intro that's cool so now
i'm trying to
in a sense maybe i'm like reverse
engineering a way for me to learn how to
acting is by just actually giving the
emotions that i when i write these
things
i'm like oh when you're when you say a
line you're supposed to visualize it
you're not you're not just saying it you
don't just say the word yeah
oh that's what acting is so in a weird
backward sense i feel like i am
pushing myself to learn how to act a
little bit right and maybe you know it
depends it depends but yeah right now no
no no no no you've kind of done so much
in the time that you've been on youtube
like is there anything you haven't done
that you want to do eventually down the
line
because i feel like when you just think
about like even just smosh stuff it's
like you guys have literally been at the
top you've done everything you've done
all the big top twice
and you know like you've done the movies
you've done you know did you release a
book
uh
we released uh a graphic novel like okay
yeah yeah i had a lot of fun most people
don't even know that existed because
they did not market it but i put my
heart soul into a graphic novel but no
no actual book right right that's
something i never is that something
you'd want to try or is that like
something else we just like eventually
i'd like to do it maybe i thought about
putting together some kind of like
coffee table book that
goes through the different interviews
i've done and talks about the different
things that i learned from each
interview the things that i've taken
from that and been able to apply to my
own life and the moments that stood out
to me
right um key things that i now go back
to and think about yeah so an
autobiography
a little bit but yeah hopefully it could
be also a way for people to
learn through me learning like that's
right that's part of why i do
the interview series i mean to be fair
if there's anyone who has enough
material to write a cohesive
autobiography yeah
i don't i don't know if i feel like
putting it in the term of autobiography
i'm like uh
who have written autobiographies yeah
and you know they're just like
i'm 24.
this video is sponsored by tipsy tipsy
is a quarterly subscription sake box
where you will get six curated sake
bottles straight from japan to try all
sorts of pairings and dishes with it
guys come on you know you want to try
some new sake right come on well why
don't you guys try some out while i give
you some pointers well luckily joe we
have some custom sake boxes that we made
just for my wedding oh my lord i know
get the full japanese i actually get to
use it this time
so the one that connor is drinking right
now is the toyo beijing this particular
brew gives an aroma red apple that fades
to an almost nutmeg spice it's a very
dry sucker said to be strong enough to
kill a devil that's actually quite nice
actually yeah i told you good that's
good what am i drinking joey well god
you're drinking the kinoyane junmai
ginjo the sucker itself is bursting with
enticing aroma and pristine flavor the
hints of freshly sliced apple and a
crisp finish that's actually really good
so guys if you want some amazing deals
in your circuit then you get 10 off all
products using code trash taste 10 and
you can get 30 off your first sake box
by using trash taste 30. is that two
coupon codes that's two coupons
different deals guys smash that link
back to the episode i i i have to ask
cause i'm curious because you've been on
youtube for so long sorry does that do
you hate it
no
because you know youtube has gone
through a lot of distinct eras i'd say
yeah yeah do you have a favorite youtube
era where you feel like this is when it
was the golden time of youtube yeah yeah
i i think it was probably around
like 2011 to 2013-ish yeah yeah where
there was money to be made so you and
sponsors like people would take it
seriously enough to fund everything yeah
but yet there wasn't this idea that like
mainstream media had yeah of like
anyone can do this and become a
millionaire yeah i mean i feel like it
was still very independent
and
it just felt like creativity was what
thrived most yeah yeah because i feel
like that era of youtube all of the
biggest creators at that time
they all started youtube not to make
money but just because they enjoyed the
creativeness of it you enjoyed making
videos and then i feel like after that
kind of progressed into people realizing
that you could make this a job
absolutely and you could like people did
it and it could be a business yeah which
is it's a legitimate business which is
nothing wrong with that but i feel like
part of the magic was lost i feel you
know because it kind of transitioned to
into something else you know
yeah a different mindset going into
creating things uh and around that time
or soon after
is when i think the algorithm was
introduced ah yes the illusive the
algorithm
the one god of youtube
i'm learning more now that the algorithm
really does reward the things that
people enjoy consuming yeah yeah yeah
and the algorithm's goal well no one
individual knows
everything in and out because it's made
by so many people and it's taught to
learn
that's not scary don't worry
the algorithm does
reward the things that that do have the
highest retention they have
uh you know watching for the longest
time replaying the moments most the
highest click-through rate of what looks
most exciting so i am learning that you
can work with the new way that it's set
up but it was definitely jarring when it
first happened and no one knew or was
told what was happening just like
flipped to let's plays overnight yeah
yeah yeah
the fastest way to make repeating
long-form content yeah people would feel
the need to watch entirely yeah oh yeah
is it cause did you guys start the
gaming channel around that time yeah
yeah is that why because of the change
or was it we didn't realize we didn't
know what the reason was that these
videos were popping up but we saw oh
wait gaming videos that's becoming
really popular people want to see this
and a lot of people are asking us to
play
did you have a hard time when the
algorithm did shift and you were still
on like you know uh scripted you know
scripts
sorry scripted sketches and everything
like that yeah yeah it was definitely a
hard period i mean it didn't really
affect us as much as
yeah it seemed like yeah
yeah yeah yeah we're still fine we still
uh i looked recently we still have like
a lot of videos from that time that have
like tens of millions of views so like
it was okay it was okay but um it
definitely did impact
the way that the videos were pushed out
initially yeah so like after the first
weekend
i remember having a higher up breathing
down my neck saying you guys usually get
a million views in the first three days
what's going on why are there you know
it was a lot of like the stress of like
what is going on and we're like i don't
know no we don't have any [ __ ] boss
telling you that yeah
and like their their entire company and
all the x amount of employees like their
livelihoods are built on the performance
of these videos right so at that time we
were really pushed to break off and
create other side channels and
experiment with longer form content
things that required less editing
i feel so lucky being like just like uh
almost always independent like a one two
man team with my own my personal channel
because that's just the pressure's just
gone it's a lot less pressure yeah okay
so because like i gotta ask because i
rarely meet someone who's been on
youtube for longer than me for longer
than most of your viewers lives yeah
because
honestly
honestly yeah yeah i just interviewed
who's like this really popular twitch
streamer and she's 19. i was like so i
made my on youtube when you were two
and it freaked me out that's scary it
freaked me the [ __ ] out because i found
out today actually that today out of
complete coincidence is my 15th year
anniversary on youtube
yeah yeah
so what is the secret to staying
relevant for a long period of time on
youtube
you're asking them
because you've been on for longer than
me so so you're the only one i can ask
for like like a actual perspective right
okay okay well we could share
perspectives here okay i think that you
might have something to contribute okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i'll be mr seven seventeen coach my
senior
my senior now my youtube career uh can
watch an r-rated movie but i can't quite
vote or smoke
mine's in high school you know yeah yeah
yours is gonna be legal next year you're
getting your first zits and trying to be
very
very uncomfortable
you're very uncomfortable about puberty
yeah yeah you're starting to get the
hang of it
yeah um but let's see so the secret
the secret is to never feel like you
have it figured out right yeah the
secret i think is to always feel like
there is something new to learn yeah uh
i i am constantly looking at the people
that are growing audiences and i'm kind
of filtering out okay this person they
have a recipe and it pleases the
algorithm
i think maybe that's why they have used
okay what can i learn from that okay
this person has a really dedicated fan
base they don't necessarily appeal to
the algorithm but they appeal to an
audience and what can i learn from them
yeah so for me it's really about
constantly learning yeah and uh when i
do interviews with bigger names uh
tomorrow i'm i'm interviewing tommy in
it
oh nice and uh you know he's got he's
he's like is he 18. he's in school right
yeah but uh like i i love picking his
brain and and you know people that are
new and coming up yeah on youtube right
now and and learning
what what they see in the platform now
because it's something completely
different and i feel like there was
never a point where you as a creator on
the internet where things are so rapidly
changing there is never a point where
you will be like
got the figured it out yeah
like and i used to think there would be
a point that i would be like i gotta
grind and grind and grind and eventually
i have it figured out and then i'll just
be able to sit back and let the thing
just live on its own
and i think that's kind of what got me
into
uh or convinced me that like selling to
a company in 2011 was a right idea i had
it in my head yeah the goal is to figure
this out it'll go on autopilot i can
relax and maybe do other things in my
life yeah um but what i quickly realized
is that i really love doing this and
this is part of my life that i want to
retain yeah and there will never be a
point where i feel satisfied just
relaxing but also if you sit back and
relax
um
then
uh you know and it's because
yeah you're comfortable when you lose
track of what's
you know why things are moving in the
direction they're going and what is
relevant to the platform today yeah
because that's really interesting to
hear because like for your perspective
you've really like been one of the top
creators basically since the birth of
youtube whereas i've been on youtube for
a long time but i've it's been like on a
very very niche like topic which is
anime so i've always been able to learn
from what the bigger creators are doing
and try to apply what you know to try to
apply what everyone else is doing and
seeing if i can take that into my own my
own niche my own channel and seeing
seeing if it can grow out of there and
how was that paid off like were you able
to take those those lessons and things
that you learned from the bigger
youtubers and apply it to yourself and
have it pay off yeah i mean i kind of
felt like a cheat sheet you know i kind
of feel like cheating because i'm just
like you know i'm in such a niche topic
that i could just take what i can just
take what other people are doing yeah i
just put it to put it with my own
content but with you since you're one
you're one of the people setting the
standards you know one of people like
you know i watched and i was like okay
let's see what smart should do let's see
what some of the other bigger creators
are doing i'm like okay well i see
what's successful to them but like i
feel like being at the top of the
pyramids and trying to balance yourself
is a lot easier than climbing up from
the bottom of the pyramid and trying to
like stay relevant for sure yeah i think
that some people uh see that see have a
goal
like get to the top of this pyramid just
just stay afloat up here yeah and of
course like it is much more comfortable
because you have the freedom to kind of
um apply more of these things that you
learn on a bigger scale yeah but at the
same time
there's so much more pressure and i
think that that's unforeseen to smaller
creators you know i had my period i left
smosh when i think we had 22 or 23
million subscribers huge amount of
subscribers huge amount of pressure i go
off and do my own thing
um channel starts with a couple million
and they're like people that don't
really know what to expect i don't know
what to give them and there was still
that pressure there from me
of
how am i going to entertain these people
who expect me to be giving the quality
of content of a 22 million subscriber
channel but now
um it's just me it's literally just me
on my yeah my own i'm really curious
about
obviously a lot of the viewers when you
you said i'm leaving smosh i think a lot
of people would see that and think oh
it's just like uh he's just leaving a
channel but i imagine there was a lot of
probably behind the scenes or like
friendships that were strained by that
yeah was that like a like outside of
just a business perspective do that put
like a lot of strain on like your
personal life like leaving that and put
having to kind of be like all right i'm
leaving this big thing like that because
you know obviously ian is there and a
bunch of your friends
there well surprisingly me leaving
didn't put a strain
in and of itself like the idea of
leaving and then me leaving yeah that
didn't exactly put a strain i think
maybe afterwards it did a little bit
because there were
really i think it was because audiences
or viewers and commenters really were
having all these different things that
they were saying about like oh this
person's better or this person is better
or you were better when you were here or
they're better now that they're here and
i think that that added a little bit of
it was unavoidable to see those
especially yeah yeah i feel like you
can't turn off your brain from wanting
to to to keep up with the comments not
even if you're not even trying to look
for that yeah yeah i'm trying to see
what people are thinking about
this new thing that i'm just like uh
trying to figure out and then i'm
getting inundated with all these
opinions from people and i think that
that does seep in when you're not ready
for it yeah i do wish that i was more
ready for the types of comments how the
[ __ ] can you get ready for that
the only way to be ready for it i think
is to live in it yeah yeah yeah
but i also realized that there is a bit
of freedom in having a smaller audience
yeah so it was it was a huge struggle
and my videos when i first left i think
got a million views each for like a
couple
months and i was like oh this is i i
need to retain this and then very
quickly once i think people realize i
didn't know what i was doing i had no
channel i was like uh each week we'll
figure out something new and i hope you
watch it uh and i
i quickly
lost this audience that i had and
realized that they were not there just
for me yeah and it was a little bit
disappointing at first because i thought
oh i i guess i have the freedom to do
whatever and i thought that i had
that with me and it was a wake-up call
to realize oh but you have to make good
content you can't just expect them
and i
uh you know the views i think got to
about
like thirty thousand to sixty thousand
views a video
on the anthony
in the first year after wow and and at
that time
you know if videos weren't getting 100
000 views or even more people in the
comments are just like irrelevant
ireland
abandon an audience for a different
style yeah obviously that's gonna happen
yeah like people don't see it like that
they're like oh your name is like what
do you mean you're not doing sketches
anymore
i thought you were gonna do your own
sketches now right i thought that i had
to i thought i was beholden and i think
that the reason that it got to that
point is i felt like i was trapped in
this idea of yeah i need to create
sketches i need to be funny i need to
deliver something that appeases that
audience that i've learned how to
appease yeah yeah and um
i think
getting down to
you know i call them lower numbers 30 to
60k i know a lot of people yeah are up
and coming and that is a great
perspective i don't want to discount
that yeah but uh at the same time
i i was like
kind of floundering around at that
number and
first of all i had to get out of my head
from looking at the numbers right it
wasn't about that anymore i realized
that i had an opportunity now
to experiment without the pressure of an
audience so that's when i started
experimenting with
all these different types of videos and
all these different types of things and
that's when i fell into
uh doing i spent a day with yeah yeah
yeah videos right and it was without
that pressure and the first few were did
have that pressure on me to be funny so
i was kind of you know i did i spent a
day with flat earthers and it was kind
of like look how
ridiculous people are weird but slowly
uh slowly but surely over the next um
couple months or half year i
i started realizing that i actually was
really curious about different types of
people
and uh i had
uh i did this video i spent today with
furries and i had a
company help me reach out to these
people and i thought they were all local
yeah when they showed up i found out
that one flew in themselves on their own
dime and then this person uh like drove
three hours to be there and i was like i
was like okay this is and i wasn't i
already wasn't planning to like
to to say like these people are weird
but a part of me was like i don't
understand this
this is this is kind of a weird thing
yeah but
you know they get there and they're
they're saying
uh i used to watch smosh all the time
so anyway why are you in yeah
so i very quickly uh changed my
perspective with the way that i went
into that it was like there's there was
no way like and it felt it felt weird to
me
uh doing that the flat earther episode
it felt weird to me like i was going
outside of my element to to give the uh
snarky commentary channel perspective
that was really popular on youtube at
the time i feel like i realized i was
kind of falling into those tropes that
were so popular yeah yeah and i was like
i just feel like i need to just be me
and have a conversation with someone be
curious about them try to learn about
their life
and
in doing so
afterward i had uh you know them reach
out to me they were really they were
really excited about the way it turned
out but also a lot of commenters were
like whoa this is the first time i've
ever seen furries represent in a way
where they were treated with respect
right and that is so weird i've never
seen that before i'm going to send this
to my friends who don't understand me
and it was really then that i realized
like oh this is what actually feels
right this is yeah this doesn't feel
like i'm not appeasing an audience i
think i should be appeasing because it's
the trendiness of youtube at the time or
yeah or like this sense of humor that i
felt like i needed to always like be
this character that i was on smosh right
i felt like i was able to actually just
be myself
and my editor then helped me throw in
jokes but it wasn't up to me anymore i
was just making a connection with yeah
yeah back to like youtube boomer talk
right yeah
you talk you talked about you know
constantly learning constantly seeing
what's out there there must have been a
point when you're just like i am so out
of touch right now oh i always because i
constantly feel that sometimes i'm like
i get youtube i get i get the algorithm
i get all the content but i get what
people want to watch sometimes you just
see something and you're like okay i am
a boomer you see that one popular video
and you're like why yeah why there's
this one channel uh called ouija pg
have you heard of that no no okay so uh
i don't know how they do it they it's
they got um
they like they have a 3d cg
rig of
luigi and they animate him in his face
to to react to things or at least this
is what this is what the channel was a
few years ago i don't know what they're
doing now okay uh so he was reacting to
things with
luigi sound effects they're like wow
and it was just like a reaction channel
by luigi and i was like
some of them had millions of views and i
was like this is so bizarre
but i loved it
that was incredible i reached out i
followed him on twitter i was like this
[ __ ] keep it up this shit's sick but it
was so weird and that's i was like there
is always something to learn
about youtube yeah yeah yeah there's
always some weird corner yeah
and i mean now you're exploring that
yeah now you're exploring yeah yeah yeah
and those are the types of people that i
really really enjoy talking to where
it's like this community that's doing
this thing that's that many people just
think is bizarre like no yeah there's
actually something to it and why does it
catch on and we could talk about the
emotional aspects of
like uh the connection that people make
and why do you think this is popular i
think it's just really refreshing you
know i mean obviously lately on the
internet you know and even when you
started it it was very competitive and
everyone was always at each other's
throat and i think it just came out of
the time and kind of hit the right note
of just like let's just talk let's just
yeah yeah
learn about each other yeah to be open
yeah yeah and i i think it's yeah i mean
the success i mean it shows that the
audiences wanted that kind of content
like yeah yeah people are curious about
all the types of different things be it
pony
pony players
[Music]
there have been a couple of videos i've
seen from yours where you do kind of
bring back that like old school like a
little bit cynical type of interviewer
type thing like you know the one about
like you interviewing time travelers for
instance like that one was like a little
like i saw like the little bit of the
super cool side yeah which was just as
entertaining you have to be yeah yeah
yeah yeah that was right after the flat
earthers episode
quite detached
yeah
um
but i feel like now if i were to
approach that again the topic that i'm
like a little bit like
yeah i think i would just outright say
this seems completely unbelievable right
yeah do you have people telling you that
and how do you feel about that right
yeah i feel like there's so many more
interesting conversations to have about
that
and i think a lot of people are uh
either afraid to tell someone that their
shit's whack or they
all they want to do is tell them that
their shit's wack and they don't want to
hear why they do what they do right
i think that there's like if you could
just be transparent with
anyone really like if you just have a
conversation with anyone about why they
do what they do
you can make some kind of a connection
regardless of who the person is except
hitler not hitler
yeah they grow up so far
he's he's maturing
how do you feel about how do you feel
about tick tock because if there's one
thing that does make me feel like a
boomer and out of touch it is just tick
tock itself
yeah
have you thought about adventuring into
that oh we i have a tic tac
yeah
yeah it does really well with just clips
from
my my interview series cut down and yeah
we did that as well yeah yeah yeah it
doesn't work for you guys yeah yeah yeah
yeah well i think that the thing about
tick tock is that there is a an audience
for everything oh yeah so you might log
on and think this is [ __ ] weird [ __ ]
but then
there is a corner of the internet that
is for you on tick tock and their
algorithm is really good at feeding you
content eventually if you get even if
you sift through enough garbage for
enough time and eventually yeah you will
find the thing that that sits
my favorite category of tip-top videos
is somebody complaining about something
really specific and then someone's like
hi i'm the expert on that actually
that's actually why it works and it's
like who's who's the toenail expert why
don't you come here
it's literally irl reddit right
let me explain yeah you it's just like
the the strangest experts all come out
and they're all good looking like that's
the other thing everyone who is like an
expert on something is just amazing
looking yeah there is always an expert
about everything and they look amazing
and they're always like amazing why did
you have to be so good and charming did
they become good looking because they're
an expert or which one came first they
became an expert then they had the time
to go and walk out and take care of them
or is it that most people that look good
or bound to be experts
i used to be a model now i'm a toenail
waiter
it is really crazy yeah but it's such a
cool platform but it makes me feel
really old yeah and it's weird because i
thought it was going to die
i think everyone when it when it was
bought when it was musically yeah yeah
yeah
i thought it was going to go down the
vine route back yeah yeah yeah musically
it was the thing and everyone was doing
the musically like cringe compilations
right i just thought that's just [ __ ]
for kids and then yeah
wow everyone was wrong i think everyone
thought it was going to die yeah yeah
yeah when everyone just was just like
that lip syncing or doing dances and
it's like oh look at this funny thing
the kids are doing they were nice man
anthony was like i did that
in my career that way they took my [ __ ]
i think it's the replies the replies and
the ability to share the music so easily
yeah yeah game changer i think yeah and
it made editing kind of
you know accessible to the i mean
editing uh very accessible to beginners
and like yeah people who don't know it
it's like you just slide this thing
across chop the video chuck it in put
this music over it and oh you want a
funny filter we've got that too yeah so
it kind of made it more like less scary
i mean you open up like da vinci resolve
and you just have a panic attack you're
like what the [ __ ] is this like this
makes no sense adobe premiere it makes
zero sense if you don't watch five hours
of youtube yeah yeah yeah so i feel like
it kind of made it like very accessible
in a way that kind of just worked and
tick tock is always changing their [ __ ]
yeah yeah if you look at tik tok now
versus a year ago it looks very
different for that and the features that
they add
they are doing the upkeep yeah
vine
like they i mean i think it was clear
why vine died for many reasons one being
that you couldn't make money on it but
also
they were not like keeping it up they
were not updating it and then
unfortunately or not
things on the internet platforms are
need to constantly be updated to go
where people are wanting it to go yeah
because it is ultimately four people
right yeah yeah instead vine opted to be
like what if we made a sequel to vine
let's make a vine too did they ever do
that
no no were those rumors or were those
legit they were they were legit yeah
vine was like we're coming back with
vine to people and then tick tock was
like nah yeah i was like no we go
yeah well i find it really weird because
like i feel like now tick tock is what
youtube was like you know 10 15 years
ago right where you know like remember
when in back in the day where youtubers
would try to get on tv which was like
the old media in order to legitimize
themselves and now it's like tick tock
is trying to become youtubers
themselves it's been so weird just
seeing that
transition i guess it's because the
platform is so easily accessible yeah
you were saying that anyone could jump
on there and you can build an audience
yeah on there people can find you the
algorithm is very good so it's basically
like
if early youtube had an algorithm that
fed people content that was directly
relevant to them yeah and i think it's
also like the barrier for entry for
youtube now i feel like even though you
know youtuber is like you know you can
make anything on youtube and it will be
successful you know still like the the
quality of content on youtube now is so
much higher than it was
15 years ago we're in like the the mr
beast era where everything has to be a
hundred thousand dollars
i [ __ ] stayed up for one week
straight yeah
it's like all right okay i can't compete
with that because i just don't want to
do that yeah have you seen any of ryan
trehan's
so he i feel like he's been reinventing
uh yeah yeah what youtubers can now
expect to do with the platform because
he's taking some elements of the mr mrb
style
thumbnails that look very nice and clean
and he has
an elevated concept right for this whole
thing it feels like a video game it
feels like you're watching this person's
journey
in front of you and you feel like you
can't click away because you never know
what's going to happen
but yet it is still a vlog and he can
still
um you know because it is a
vlog where the whole idea is that it's
low produced yeah he's able to make one
a day it's quite nice yeah watching it
and you're like this is like nice i just
feel like it's not too crazy yeah like
you know obviously love nostalgia i love
watching a mr beast video but my god i
feel like i'm a cog in a machine
yeah like absolutely so and there's so
much screaming and texting yeah
it feels like a refined modernized vlog
that has yeah yeah kind of like an
elevated
game plan the thumbnails are just the
thumbnails kill it and i never would
have thought that a vlog thumbnail which
is not you know
clickbait because it's not clickbait it
couldn't look so good yeah right
i don't know who do you like i remember
when you know where back when uh you
know youtuber vlogs were just you know
you put on any digital camera you know
handheld camera and then casey neistat
came along and just used a dslr and made
like basically like mini short films
every day and people were like what you
can do that that's possible and then
everyone try to be casey neistat for a
while and then he broke up and then he
burnt out you know i mean he was every
day yeah i mean when he used to talk
about his schedule he was like yeah i'd
wake up at 4 a.m and i'm editing it on
the plane i'm like yeah what the [ __ ]
but i think what we can learn from that
experience is
that you know if you have something good
you don't need to over do it yeah if you
wanted to have any longevity you know
part of the game plan is to figure out a
way for it not to take up your entire
life yeah you know i interviewed market
player and he was like burnout is when
people aren't refilling their bucket
they're they're constantly scooping out
of their bucket for their content and
they're refilling it because they're not
living a life outside of that yeah you
need to have that balance yeah have you
ever been burnt out uh
yes absolutely
i was
shocked if you said no i've been like
yeah
it's always uh
i was trying to be polite the question
should be so when did you burn out
like that
many different times and every single
time it was when i felt overworked
um and then once it became like part of
a company overworked underappreciated
yeah um felt like i wasn't being um like
my my opinions didn't
uh quite contribute to the creative
right um but then also outside of that i
i was burnt out on my own outside of
smosh after i left and decided to do my
own thing right um for a lot of that
time
when the views were dropping
uh i was also burnt out so it makes
sense that people were not wanting to
watch the content of someone who's
burned the [ __ ] out by their own content
that's like that's not fun to watch
there's a feeling you can feel when
someone is burnt out by their yeah and
then and then when you go to the the
actual video and the top comment is like
he's run out of ideas
i'm like [ __ ] you dude i got so many
ideas and i just sit there like i have
no idea
they were right [ __ ]
call me but uh you know i
i think i i really
started to reframe
what was important to me and then i
started like not taking it as seriously
not putting as much of my time into it
and i was able to
live a life outside of it and have
thoughts that were separate from my work
that's right it kind of helps
reinvigorate
yeah one thing i was going to ask is
like because you know
compared to
you youtube boomers right here we are
like we are very much children oh yeah
nine years seven years right seven years
yeah like i just discovered what boogers
taste
so it's like what i wanted to ask uh you
specifically is like
how much of longevity do you see
as a youtuber being a career right
because it's like we don't really have
any like you know because like instead
of like you know hollywood or like the
acting industry or music industry right
yeah we already have examples of people
who have had careers for like 30 40 50
years yes right but because youtube is
such a new thing whereas like i think
the longest is probably someone like you
right it's like do you see yourself
doing this for the next 10 15 years
again i mean it's already been half my
life yeah so it feels
like i can give my confidence to the
idea that youtube will be around for a
long time right they haven't made any
glaring
mistakes that are still glaring mistakes
like it feels like they've made a ton of
mistakes absolutely i'm not gonna write
them off completely but it seems like
over time they are
remedying a lot of those it feels like
they actually are caring about the
community i'm not you know there's
plenty of issues but
it seems like
enough people care to make changes to
keep the platform relevant yeah right
because like it's going come back
i completely lost it
because obviously people are going to be
like what do you mean
yeah and it's like i think as you were
saying as a whole platform i think they
they meant considering the amount of
[ __ ] that goes on the platform yeah yeah
they do a pretty good job at keeping it
relevant pushing it forward and making
it the place yeah yeah obviously there's
this place yeah because i think
definitely like the the one
moment that youtube like did a [ __ ]
and everyone was like this is the end of
youtube was when demonetization became a
thing right yeah and the ad apocalypse
came out everyone unanimously was like
this is it this is where this is where
it dies yeah but it somehow managed to
stick around for what five extra years
that needed to happen though yeah yeah
looking back at it it was an
inevitability that it was gonna come to
something like yeah a system like that
was gonna have to be pleasant yeah they
implemented a lot of things that help
with that though like on the back end
you can upload a video now and it'll say
um i'm not sure if it's for everyone i
think it's whatever
you correct me in my problems
right here
bro we do not have any of those features
and then after a half hour 45 minutes an
hour whatever it eventually does like
the initial check and then you can have
some confidence yeah that probably
caught it if it's going to catch
something that you shouldn't have in the
video yeah so that has given me a lot of
confidence in the direction of that
because monetization was a huge issue
every time i would upload for a while i
was like um i don't know let's see this
thing i put tens of thousands of dollars
into it might
be worth nothing i might just be in the
red for this right they did fix some
things i feel and they're slowly but
surely i think fixing a lot of the
glaring issues yeah was there like a
point where like this changed from you
know because
as with the way being a content creator
is this changed from being a job to a
career because like for the longest time
i treated youtube as a job because you
wake up and you're like maybe i'll be
irrelevant
tomorrow a week from now a year and like
i didn't really feel like this was a
career literally until this podcast when
i'm just like oh okay this is like a
business sustainable business that i can
see myself
you know five ten years in the future is
that was there a point for that for you
i think the moment that that changes
with somebody in general is probably
when you have a format that you know you
can come back to and feel confident in
and that's probably why this podcast was
like we know the format yeah yeah you
know it's kind of all figured out so
that it feels like this is a repeating
thing yeah um for me it was
i think it probably felt like career
when i mean when we were purchased by
defy because right right right we had
salary and salary i mean that that kind
of i feel like is unique to me though
yeah um but then
after that you know going off
independently the moment that it felt
like a career for me now was when i had
a series i spent a day with to go back
to yeah yeah
it was a repeating like a safety net
like some something comfort you know i
think that's the difference yeah when it
when you know that you have something
you're not starting from square one
every single video yeah you know a lot
of people are still trying to figure out
what they're doing so every single video
is back to the drawing board and that
just feels like a job and trust me it's
tough yeah because like i feel like when
you're starting off at youtube you want
to make like every video like a 10 out
of 10 banger you want to be motivated
you want to do something new every time
then you realize that after a year or
two of doing it you're like this is not
sustainable that's all i need i need
some kind of formula that i can fall
back on because i can't always be you
know at my peak of creativity every time
yeah yeah so you guys are like 90
probably going into each episode 90 sure
where things are gonna go you know and
that
that
yeah
yeah well going back to the beginning of
the service
well roughly we know roughly you know a
little bit about what the dynamic is
going to be like obviously i know if i
say this thing
or maybe he'll react
all i know is that we're going to have
someone on the show
and we're going to be talking about
their stuff well you have a name and you
have sponsors yeah exactly exactly yeah
yeah i guess like sorry no i was just
saying like i feel like in in a weird
way
we're still trying to figure out that
formula for trash taste in in a sense
it's like we've kind of figured it out
you know it's obviously like a lot of
colored episodes deep down
but it's like i'm i'm personally always
like yeah you know scared of like that
that moment where it starts to get
repetitive or stuff you feel like a job
and like luckily it's how i i don't feel
that way right now about it but it's
like i am scared to like fall into that
so what are you doing to prevent it from
feeling like it's a repetitive job oh i
mean we're bringing it on tour now
i mean we're yeah we're filming overseas
we're getting you know all sorts of
interesting guests and stuff like that
and i think the specials definitely help
yeah where that's like that's the moment
where we can just like kind of really
explode without creativity yeah but also
those specials probably are what excite
the audience as well right yeah yeah
yeah i hope so
right guys every now and then be like
where's our four-hour conversation i
wanted to go to work and listen to four
hours and watch one hour of content yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah i guess like my final question is
what do you want to do in the future i
mean you've been on the platform 17
years yeah is there something for your
20th anniversary
got nothing planned man but 21st you
don't know
um
i think i mean i just want to continue
refining what i do
that's what i've been enjoying doing
most uh this i spent a day with series
has been so fun for me because every
single every single episode i see at
least one element that i want to refine
whether it's the lighting on the set or
something that's like really
technical like that or it's like my
uh
performance on the intros feels like i'm
just reading words i'm gonna you know
revamp that and try to learn it or like
i
i just went all out i did these tests
where i reshot some of my intros where i
have a jib like right which is like a
[ __ ] little crane yeah
camera and i was like what if i because
i was watching a bunch of really big
youtubers yeah you know like erect for
example and i was like
he has these intros where he's like
choreographed this scene
um there's one that he either like about
like
what would you do if you had one day
right so he starts off and it's like the
doctor's saying you have one day left to
live and he's like in these bandages and
then he's like he just gets up and he
gets out and the doctor is like where
are you going and he's like ripping off
his bandages stuff he's like talking to
the camera he's like what would you do
if you had one day left to live and he's
like
to the audience and he's bringing us
through the cameras like following him
and it's like this choreographed scene
that
just immediately right off the bat you
know
there was this effort that went into
this this is a good setup for this video
because i know that if the rest of this
video is like anything like this first
30 seconds it's gonna be so much fun
yeah yeah so i was like how could i
apply some of these things that i'm
seeing modern youtubers do right uh and
apply it to an interview format i was
like i can kind of choreograph the way
that i say these things so i'm still
learning with that and
so it's hard to say like where i want to
go next but
i think more importantly i know
where i want to go now and that's to
constantly
refine and not allow myself to get bored
because i want to always creatively
see where what is like right out of my
comfort zone it's really cool that
you've been on youtube for that long
yeah i still want to get inspiration
that's very humbling yeah like it's
inspiring to hear that like you are
still on your journey right
yeah after 70 yeah after 17 years you're
still on your journey and you're still
figuring stuff out yeah because in my
head i was like damn i've been doing
this [ __ ] for nine years i don't know
what the [ __ ] i'm doing i'm glad to know
someone who's been doing it for almost
double that also doesn't know wow you're
not having fun man it's yeah if i'm if i
enjoy what i'm doing like i feel like
that is
the best career that you could have yeah
that's where you enjoy it not not the
career that you know unfolds in this
timeline that i pre-built in my head for
where it goes right yeah yeah you hear
that guys it's not about the money
it's about the love for it but yeah
thank you so much for coming on
this is awesome
hey but look at all these patrons though
yeah
hey if you like to support the show go
to our patreon patreon.com also follow
us on twitter send us some memes on the
subreddit and if you hate our face
listen to us on spotify yeah and uh yeah
go check out anything stuff i don't need
to tell you that
everyone should know yeah yeah well i
hope we did an okay job interviewing you
yeah yeah yeah
absolutely i've never done a three on
one before
i've always been on one on three
thank you for putting me in the reverse
position yeah all right hopefully we're
gonna hear about our uh our skills later
on yeah yeah write it all down as a
score
no i'll talk about this experience on
another episode of my show oh my gosh
you won't know when it's coming
you're just gonna throw it and be like
oh yeah but yeah so about the pony thing
so i came in there they didn't know
anything they didn't know anything they
weren't even prepared you're such a
better guest than than trash tape
and they weren't even guests they were
hosts
hell yeah i appreciate it thank you
thank you and thanks for watching guys
see you next time
[Music]
you